to me that number one criteria for
helping me coach these kids are people
who have legendary and unique voices
that we all know and I think that this
guy other than being a friend of mine
really epitomizes that it's inspiring to
musicians like myself hearing these
young people sing ago Gina I think I'm
gonna brand-new son I'm gonna go get my
voice together he's a badass singer and
I'm gonna stop kissing his ass though
that's it once more
Sammy Hagar you're my hero this is Ellie
Esparza this is Ponciano sail on in and
we're Team Adam this whole experience
auditioning for the voice coming out to
LA it's mind-blowing it's it's humbling
and it's probably the greatest
experience especially because I meet
people like you exactly I feel the same
way I feel like every day I wake up and
it feels like a dream
yeah it's Natasha Natasha laughs like
all the time like all the time seem
energetic very nice Black's Riley is
really kind and I think he's just really
funny but I don't think he means to be
funny
there they go alright I like the
attitude I ready you're gonna pick
I'd literally sat at home and watch
these shows and then like these people
aren't really friends but like we are
really so unreal the way it's worked out
with you and I though you've always been
so encouraging to me from the moment you
met when you were telling me positive
things
Johnny you're like a Latin unicorn on
fire look at someone coming in here
saying my first impression of you was
pretty like lay back just chill vibe
yeah I got that friendship quality for
me when I first saw you and then I heard
your voice and I was like please don't
put me up against her team Adam is
dynamic we have such a wide variety of
voices and backgrounds and perspectives
on this team the arrangement you guys do
is so intricate and so did on the mind
that was killin ya it's an awesome
feeling to be with a singer that you're
fighting with you know but in a fun way
it's a really really great match and I'm
very happy to be a part of it with him I
would say team Adam is definitely a team
full of unique characters everyone's
really funny - I'm on my way to LA with
and our puppy I actually haven't heard
you sing until the blind audition yes I
don't know how similar voices laughing
you guys voices sounding so the bigger
particulars sure it's right
Sammy the greatness is the man like he
gave me such great advice I'd be careful
both you guys have the tendency to over
sing and use too many licks when things
get exciting but you can do it yeah this
is what I've done my whole life you work
up harmonies and you get your parts
right so the easiest job of pepper head
walking into I'm digging this show it's
like wow he's the luckiest guy in TV
right
you